hey guys I'm Ryan right this is Anthony
this is Chloe so uh right now we're
gonna watch the trailer in case you guys
haven't seen us yet this is um my
brother my niece hello we're gonna watch
the Melo Master Chief collection trailer
I am definitely gonna buy that I what is
it it's a collection of all the Master
Chief games from Halo one two three and
four they have other Halo games like I
forgot the names of the other ones but
they weren't as interesting and so this
is consolidating all of them there's the
anniversary edition or something for
Halo one is being ported from Xbox 360
but they're making a brand new special
edition for Halo 2 and that's why a lot
of people want this in addition to like
improved graphics for Halo 3 and for
like I think on Xbox 360 halo 4 ran at
30 frames but on Xbox one it'll run at
60 all of them are gonna was supposed to
run at 60 frames so it's gonna look
sweet yeah you play Halo you should
plays hello one cool well I look a lot
fatter next to you this is bad table now
I have such a round face I used to be
the skinny what happened what happened
me used to be so beautiful all right
Chloe
we're gonna watch the trailer now are
you excited I don't understand I ask you
a question your emotion shutting it okay
well that's her thumbs up thumbs up
higher there we go did you tell them
that I did an Xbox commercial no yeah
by the way guys he did an Xbox
commercial for project spark project
spark you can look it up project spark
trailer the first trailer that came out
of last year's e3
Oh
to find it you have to forget the
stories and mouse
forget the legends you have to keep warm
in his footsteps
so he is more than the sum of his
actions
I tell you this not because I trust you
Wow do this real
Master Chief collection goes the seeds
about to it said so in his fast I never
played a two and three in fact
I barely even played one only played
four you call yourself the biggest Halo
fan out there said that you declared it
right before we film you said Ryan I am
the biggest Halo fan that's ever existed
I will gladly do this trailer you're
lyin through you were I don't know much
about the Halo games whenever they're on
at a party or a friend's house I love
playing I'm pretty good at that [ __ ]
actually sorry I didn't say that word
I'm pretty good at that stuff chick
there a chick she says chick [ __ ] can we
bleep it up so I'm pretty good at a halo
when I play it I'd never played the
storyline versions this isn't this is
the clue you understand this is my
channel and there's a certain level of
quality I have to my channels that I
expect from everyone who comes on the
channel so yeah is very informal this is
not god this is no professional behavior
these viewers come here for a quality
not okay so so what do you think of the
trailer um I like trailer trailer is
good I don't know much about the halo
storyline I know that a lot of science
fiction movies are trying to be halo and
I know that the gameplay is awesome as
always but the storyline a lot of people
are more interested in that that I
actually thought they would have been so
yeah you can look it up on Wikipedia I
could read it and then come across like
I know it reshoot this yeah and then BAM
people will think I'm a smart guy it's
actually an interesting story I won't go
into it and deprive you guys of knowing
the story yourself what do you think of
the trailer it looks cool I don't know
what's happening but it looks
neato burrito you don't boo - yeah it's
a good teaser good teaser enough to make
you go I want to play this game even
though the games are gonna look like
that what I'm playing but I want to play
it's a good deal at 60 bucks for four
games oh wow it's a setup because hey
hello halo 5 is coming up next year you
have not contributed to the opinion of
halo what you think the talk about this
entire time just messing around which
are you scared of yeah you're shy I'm
shy
if I do this so I can get over my fears
little Smith words of wisdom look up the
video video all right guys if you're new
to the channel ah
thanks for let us know by the way about
that video be now if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe here
my broseph Joseph and my niece's Jesus
add a subscribe button here for Jabby
koi they also do movie related stuff
khloe's that kind of person that you
know it's like you put her just in front
of the camera to be herself she's she
has a hard time but she can express
herself finally when she has like lines
and a character to live vicariously
through Michael Ealy many of you can
figure that out
bonus points for you internet still down
it's been a funny month so internet is
down and I have to give shoutouts out to
some people
and we're gonna do one each here which
is the personal shout out then I will
continue to shout out list once the
Internet's back up I want to shout out a
person shout out hey my sister who goes
by Mary Black apparently I think she
wears this black yeah okay she thinks
she's Johnny Cash or something or she
thinks she works with the men in black
Mary black I love you I'm gonna I'm
gonna shout out to to two people Skeeter
and Michael Scott not Michael Scott from
the office Michael Scott dork man Scott
is what he goes by on the Internet's and
Claudia Morales
none of you know who these people are
and I want to shout out um the one
person who always is a shout out that'll
be our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
that's right I believe and Gandhi -
mother Teresa Socrates Budda Budda Budda
Julia Napoleon Hill I'm pulling no oh
yeah he wrote like thinking Grow Rich
thinking Grow Rich and I will have about
Anthony Robbins at that point and the
rubber on rubber cusan Les Brown
basically all you motivational speakers
up here right Chloe